foreign
[Music]
Tech news briefing for Wednesday October
26th I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
the prospect of a recession has a lot of
Executives understandably nervous but
the president and co-founder of the ride
hailing company Lyft John Zimmer says he
sees an opportunity
his take may seem a little surprising
seeing as the company's share price is
down more than 80 percent since its
initial public offering in 2019. at the
Wall Street journals of tech live
conference this week wsj business editor
Jamie Heller spoke with Zimmer about the
ride hailing sector and lifts foray into
autonomous driving
she started the conversation by showing
a slide of the Stock's decline
here are highlights John thanks so far
for being here since you guys went
public it's been quite a rough ride
yep yeah yeah
um about that so it doesn't seem like
boss keeps wall Street's quite liking it
as much as some of your customers are so
maybe you could just talk about what you
think just justifies that disconnect
sure so Liv's been around for 10 years
now and you know we've had a profound
impact if you look on the rider side
we've done over three billion rides on
the platform 34 of the US population has
taken a Lyft ride since our beginning
three percent of the US Workforce has
earned money on the Lyft platform and as
we move towards an autonomous future
what we're doing is critical to building
out that Transportation the future so
obviously yes it's been rocking oh
you're on risky ground talking about the
autonomous future but we'll get to that
but sure but of course we've faced many
challenges from the beginning first was
you know the regulatory challenges then
the competition with Uber Uber had
raised three billion dollars from the
Saudi government at a point when we had
five months of cash left and then we
went public first then got hit with a
pandemic that took out 70 to 80 of our
volume almost overnight and so that that
was a big impact on the stock we had a
cost structure that was based on we're
about to get to profitability on a
business that was four times bigger than
what it got shrunk to in the pandemic
and now we've taken our way back up got
into profitability and I'm confident as
we get through these recessionary
pressures That Wall Street will will fix
that the shape of that chart and
and going into a potentially tougher
economic environment which you guys have
already been wrestling with yeah a lot
of tech companies at the start of the
pandemic had a had a great ride you know
whether it was Zoom or Google or others
the pandemic meant a lot of people
working inside and using their products
that was not the case for us and so I
would say what's coming is actually
maybe the the third or fourth hardest
thing we've faced in terms of the coming
potential recession or the recession
that we're already in so we're ready we
have a strong team and frankly on you
know with a two-sided Marketplace on the
driver's side typically there are more
drivers looking for work in a recession
but what about on the demand side I mean
how are you seeing like higher inflation
if you look back at
inflation affects us mostly on insurance
if you look back you've added a fee for
now right uh our service fee has gone up
related to insurance if you look back at
recessions and you look at
transportation ground transportation
specifically it stays pretty static so
perhaps growth slows down in a recession
but people need to get around and so I'm
less concerned you know than if I was uh
to knock on our competitor you know in
the food delivery business in a
recession you know getting a 30 salad is
probably going to be less likely some
someone does in a recession than uh in a
pandemic but just coming back to Wall
Street and if you look back at this
chart I mean the Market's looking at it
thank you the Mark is seeming a lot more
confident and Uber's more Diversified
yeah I mean let's talk about what I was
just saying is if you go back to the
pandemic and you say hey we have a
business that delivers food to people's
homes when they're not going out that
seems like a really good idea in a
pandemic and did really well and it's a
real business it's it's long-term
there'll be a business of some sort
but we've always focused on the long
term we always believe that
Transportation itself is the largest if
you think about this whether it's a
three year five year ten year period if
you think about the opportunity we have
in front of us to affect a trillion
dollars of annual spend that's how much
is spent on Transportation every year
it's the second highest household
expense the only thing Americans spend
more money on is the house itself and
Americans spend or use their car four
percent of the time we have barely
scratched the surface of what we can do
as a business to impact and improve
transportation and save people money so
coming back to autonomous
stage and many other many other places
have been sites of many Grand
predictions about autonomous cars that
haven't come true including one from you
that they would become account for the
majority of Lyft rides within five years
that was 2016. so uh how much do you
think that that kind of thing has been a
pressure on not just your stock but Uber
Tesla also like how much was there a
high hopes for the AVS with all these
predictions built built into their
expectations I don't believe in talking
to investors I don't believe we've
actually really been given value
previously recently less or more for the
critical role we play in the autonomous
transition I do think that there was
broadly in in the tech world and maybe
Financial world there's been kind of
non-belief excitement non-belief kind of
back and forth over the last five or so
years
my opinion is it is not a matter of if
this technology comes to Market but when
and I'm highly confident that when it
comes to Market it will need to happen
on existing Transportation Network
the idea is we're going to have a hybrid
Network where the far majority of rides
for a very long time will be with
because I was wrong we'll be with human
drivers but over time you know let's say
10 percent of rides happen with an
autonomous vehicle in three years that's
not a prediction it's just hypothetical
and in three years ten percent then go
three years after that goes to 20 you'll
always as a customer want to be on a
network where you can always get a ride
I'm going to have to pause you because
my clock is up thank you so much thank
you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more coverage of this
year's Tech live conference visit our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]